Oh Unicorn is galloping so for this
costume welcome back to our show
amateur versus pro what's your favorite
their food when you like the first thing
you bust into it on the floor but not
here side side that's when I do it I'm
nasty with it next no soup no good where
do you think we'll be able to tell who
the amateur who the pro is hopefully
this one I'm right
game recognize game bring on the dancers
Wow okay I actually really like this
alien costume
a lot I want both of these and a unicorn
one is nice I wonder if they will
inhibit the dance though do you guys say
you could dance in these costumes yeah
serious question who's the pro you have
to figure it out oh it's a good answer I
don't feel comfortable to guess right
now cuz I don't was wrong I'm just gonna
guess you know what I'm gonna look
because sometimes faint nose but I'm
gonna say alien is is the print it's a
pro this is a hard I'm gonna go with her
but right now we've seen you guys went
to break into the dance moves
yeah let's get the first dancer up I
want a good clean dance no blows behind
the dope and keep your costumes on at
all times we're gonna flip a coin you're
gonna call it alright alright give it to
us alien oh oh it's a lot of swag here
I should like to play with this making
his legs other legs dance Hey
okay Oh like ears you know oh okay
Unicorn is galloping okay Wow okay okay
okay
[Music]
I dig it a lot of nice footwork
it's hard to customize I got a customer
messing it up
[Music]
okay okay okay through your finger I
like this you will unicorn get a unique
[Music]
yes honest wow wow wow wow it looks very
difficult that looks so hard to do but
you were you were keeping it up and I
love you doing your thing even though it
was difficult and around one a lot of
good dancers
yeah I like the way unicorn came out
guns blazing the energy was super high
and I feel like to me that is indicative
of the professional the the alien one
went with actually the music the music
was slow I think I'm gonna guess that
the unicorn was the pro only because of
the energy in the beginning yeah you
have alien amateur Hey but I definitely
feel like I need another round to make a
fine yes boys though alright let's bring
in the fire for the egg song next round
let's swap up the order to yeah unicorn
let's have you out there first DJ Oh
[Music]
slow move in oh oh oh okay
oh oh oh oh wow oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
Wow Wow
are you jumped in the air with this a
full aerial in this and then with the
alien was like it was great it was fun
you know what I like about him his movie
yes yes this one is a hard one
it's just really hard to me okay I think
I know what I'm missing that one move to
me the jump in the air made me think
that the unicorn is a pro and the
amateur is the alien that move there
okay it's a part for me I'm gonna go
ahead and pick that because we need a
winner and we need a loser all right
there we go I'm going to get right I'm
Josh
I am the amateur I am a dance coach for
a middle school in the San Fernando
Valley I do not do anything pro but I
really love to dance I'm Kristin Farina
and I'm the professional I'm trained in
all styles and the move that they saw as
I also do breaking tricking flips that
kind of stuff so I couldn't do much in
this outfit yeah I'm a professional you
guys are great we can't both be winners
that's the thing about the word
quote/unquote amateur is I feel like it
could be a so bra no bra can you coach
so my got foot coaching in both pros of
mine both both you both are pros am I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]